[Música]
yo voy a ir rápido porque no le va a dar
tiempo a todos supongamos 8 horas de
sueño 8 horas de trabajo y con los 8
restantes la dividimos no al menos una
hora para la comida desayuno almuerzo
merienda y cena otra hora entre lo que
tardó llega la clase o al trabajo me
vuelvo que me cortan en la cartera mi
casa de hoy no pasa que ya mi hermana
era mañana cuando se nada con mis padres
hoy que siempre voy corriendo tenéis
ahora bueno da igual déjalo
hoy tampoco voy al gimnasio por cierto
buenas tardes a todos que es que vengo
tan acelerada que ni siquiera había
saludado sigo porque de lunes a viernes
tengo universidad pero es que te vienen
a domingo me toca trabajar cuando ve a
mis amigos cuando ve a mi familia cuando
ya tenéis con mi pareja un ratito de
intimidad bueno para los que somos
estreñidos
este ritmo de vida nos viene fatal no no
no es que aún tengo que ir a comprar al
poner lavadoras pasaréis parte de
trabajo mi compañera que es muy pesada y
hasta me tengo que depilar de ahí los
pantaloncitos de hoy
puede ser que se te pare el tiempo
cuando en realidad te faltan horas en el
día
a mí se me paró
el día 1 de enero de este mismo año
concretamente a las 12 y 21 de la noche
era a fin de año nochevieja mi familia y
yo cenamos nos comimos las uvas y
salimos todos a la calle a celebrar el
año nuevo
estando todos en la acera
riéndonos echándonos fotos
mi abuela tropezó
de un traspiés y cayó a la carretera
justo en el momento en el que pasaba un
coche
o juro
que cuando te dicen la vida puede
cambiarte en un segundo
se cambia vaya a ser de cambia
se cambia y das valor a otras cosas lo
que antes era algo normal y rutinario
como un almuerzo con tu madre a veces te
parece algo extraordinario porque te das
cuenta que estás disfrutando de tu
tiempo con su tiempo
cambia tu escala de prioridades hay
cosas que le pasan a un segundo plano
pero que antes hacían un mundo y era el
mayor de los dramas problemas que hasta
te quitaban el sueño ahora ya no son tan
graves por muy mal que te vaya el día y
muchos problemas que tengas en casa en
el trabajo con tu familia con tus amigos
aprendes a relativizar lo todos los días
tienen ahora las mismas horas que antes
pero tú ya no eres la misma
es como que ahora eres consciente de que
vida sólo hay una y que ni quiere ni
puede se está perdiendo el tiempo con
tonterías
desde entonces me obligó a ver lo bueno
e incluso lo malo y se puede se puede
que a pesar de las mil cosas que marque
la agenda diaria sacar un ratito para mí
o para los míos
ese fue un instante decisivo y yo no
creo que sea necesario que tengan que
pasar cosas así para que despertemos y
cambiemos el chip no tenemos que vivir
una situación límite para que aflojamos
un poquito y valoremos un poquito más lo
que tenemos y a quienes tenemos todos
los que estamos aquí esta tarde tenemos
problemas tenemos nuestra vida nuestros
asuntos y a todos nos pueden pasar cosas
pero creo que tenemos que aprender que a
saber que a pesar de aquello que nos
ocurra tenemos que saber disfrutar de
los momentos y recomponernos
creo que se puede resumir un poco todo
en sonreír un poquito más que falta hace
muchas veces
decir más veces te quiero a la gente que
de verdad está contigo y a tu lado y
preocuparnos un poquito menos
ese fue el momento que
cambió mi vida ojalá sea este el
instante que cambie la muestra muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]